so the dogs not dead it's still alive
it is still alive yes crying my name is
Nancy Emmanuel and I am the founder of
Ozzy and Friends rescue we are dedicated
to helping animals who are homeless at
high kill shelters about to be
euthanized we rescue them and we help
place them into their forever home so
the situation today is we're gonna go to
La Plata Randall study don't see the
dogs that they have theirs are in pretty
bad shape see what dog we want to take
in to help take it to the vet and
hopefully Tyson who is helping us over
there is able to secure a foster
[Music]
there what's your name
so just so you know there's a dead
there's a dead dog that's up in here no
one's really sick the little brown one
is in bad shape and unfortunate seeing
you'll see over here to the left where
there's one that's already recently
passed this is the sum total of the food
that they have and obviously none of its
four puppies and it looks like mostly
puppy they're pets here most of most if
not all these puppies won't make it so
the dogs not dead
it's still alive oh it is still alive
yeah it's crying why don't we take that
one to the vet to be hospitalized
okay I'm gonna take you to the hospital
[Music]
- yeah you want to take two guys going
to the won the lottery so if we didn't
take this dog I mean it'd be lucky to
live through up through the week you
know maybe a couple days maybe a week
alright let's get this one okay know
that we're coming so we just rescued two
puppies from that but another that are
very very sick so we're trying to really
rush to get to the vet so that they can
be hospitalized and treated
[Music]
the vet said that the black one has a
fractured jaw
they both are extremely dehydrated and
he's going to do some tests first for
parvo distemper and lime disease
oh yeah so she's positive for powerful
so it gets complicated we don't know how
long they've had parvo the chances of
them surviving is like 50% so what he's
gonna do is he's going to hospitalized
the dogs game stable regulate their
temperatures and then give them fluids
getting him ready for his IV
[Music]
[Music]
hi hey how's it going heads up I'm
recording because I have to talk about
the video yeah I got a text from Nancy
and she said that the little black puppy
died this morning it's just too like far
too far long the other ones still alive
since he's been around parvo and all
these other diseases he's I'm sure not
allowed to be around other dogs so he
would need a foster I have a dog Nancy
has dogs so I'm not like no pressure at
all but would you
would you be open to fostering him for
it's like a seven out of time we're
getting a puppy today we didn't know
this was gonna happen but we couldn't
not take him buzz was at the clinic for
about I say three to four days and then
we were able to find a temporary foster
in Tijuana to take care of him give him
his medicine
keep him in quarantine for the last two
weeks we're driving down to Chula Vista
to basically pick him up I'm gonna
foster it
[Music]
I'm nervous because I haven't had a dog
in a long time I grew up with dogs I've
never been responsible for a dog on my
own I kind of regret not saving the mom
and everyone else I mean it's been
bothering me I've been thinking about it
but I know at the same time we can't
save them all I wish I could do more I
wish I had more manpower more volunteers
more resources more time you know but I
don't you know I can only do so much
and it's stressful
hey baby Oh alright I want him it's just
so rewarding it just makes everything
all the time and all the effort
emotionally physically financially you
know just everything it just it just
makes everything worth it it's just
that's the whole point is to be able to
just be able to get him into a good home
you know that will love them as much as
we love them because we love the dogs
he's energetic he's gained 2.4 pounds
and he has a good appetite he's got some
skin issues going on that Kelly's gonna
take him to the vet to get checked down
good skins great he has a little hair
loss like they say it takes a whole
village are you ready to go into your
part of me yes I think he's happy he
already slept on my lap for a good hour
so I'm here at the vet and
buzzes in the back they just did a
little exam and it turns out he might
have fleas he also might have mange
buzzes back he had some shots he had all
kinds of stuff actually two exams one on
his skin and one on his ears and
hopefully he's okay
I took buzz to the vet again yesterday
to get a second opinion because I
noticed that he was getting more bald
spots and he also had a really like
distended belly it was really round and
full and we found out that he has worms
both on his skin and in his stomach so I
now have to deep clean my whole
apartment I have to buy all new stuff
for him and I'm glad he's already
feeling better his belly's a little
smaller so the medicine is working this
is gonna be a whole process we're about
to do a very deep clean it's hard
because he's so adorable and I don't
want to have to confuse him by not
petting him all the time anymore or
moving all his stuff
so many people are interested in buzz
and adopting him we decided to get him a
DNA test
van guess what I just got in my email
DNA results no nacho that's what I grew
up with I don't even know what that is
51 to 84 pounds
Jesus think about how much dog food that
thing is gonna need buzz his first
collar you look handsome
our first walk with the harness that
fits he just went to buy it and he's
loving it it looks like a different dog
and he's happy yeah energy energy beauty
[Music]
hey buzz you want to live here forever
[Music]